[Music]
[Applause]
uh
albert breer one of our favorite senior
nfl reporter lead content strategist for
the monday morning quarterback
and uh back on the program we haven't
had you on since the carson wentz deal
if i would have said that's the only
offer the eagles are going to get for
carson wentz
what would you have said well first of
all perloff seems to have a
a lot of background on this uh shailene
i hadn't heard of her
before yeah
i dan i wouldn't have been surprised
like i i just think this is how the
league views him right now and
um you know when the eagles gave the
agents um
you know permission to to go and seek a
trade at the beginning of january that's
the agents found and
um you know the the eagles did get calls
after the matthew stafford deal but
uh yeah i think at that point it was
pretty clear like that carson wentz
wanted to go to indianapolis and any
other team that was
involved even tangentially was sort of
looking at it like
i don't want to invest in the guy but if
you want to give him away like we'll
take a flyer on them so
i just think what we saw on carson white
like the league
always lets us know right like i feel
like the league let us know what they
thought of matthew stafford you had the
panthers you had washington offering a
first first round picks plus something
else
you had the rams go the extra mile to
get them the league let us know what
they thought of matthew stafford
and i think in the other direction we
see now what the league thinks of carson
wentz coming off of his 2020 season
were the eagles trying to create a
market that wasn't there
yes yeah i think they did everything
they could to try to get the most that
they could and
you know in the end the bears and colts
were there the bears never put in an
offer
and i think you know a huge piece of
that was there's a number of factors
i don't know the personality fit would
have been um great there and so if you
have that plus
the guy doesn't want to necessarily come
to chicago he'd rather go to
indianapolis
you can sort of add a to b and figure
out why they never put an offer on the
table
so you know i i think that this is
probably the best
this is the best conclusion for for
carson once that he winds up
you know in indianapolis because you
know his old offensive coordinator frank
wreck is there
a guy he was very close to on the eagle
staff the last few years press taylor is
there
and those guys know how to get the most
out of him um so
you know i think you know where maybe
the rest of us saw carson once
as like well you know maybe you can get
him back to what he was in 2017 and
uh you know he still was you know a guy
who has all this talent as a former
second overall pick
the league was sort of looking at him as
somebody who right now is broken and
wasn't sure
if he could be fixed are the eagles set
at quarterback
no um i i think that
and i i'm gonna i'm gonna put a caveat
on that and saying that
it wouldn't shock me if we get to may
1st
and jalen hurts is the clear-cut starter
it also wouldn't shock me if we get to
may 1st and there's serious competition
on the roster
and that could come with a veteran but i
think it's more likely that the eagles
do everything they can to try and get
the best information they possibly can
on the three quarterbacks who
could potentially follow to them that's
zach wilson trey lance and justin fields
and i have it on good authority that
they are going to go through that
process
with each of those guys hold them up
against jalen hurts
and make a decision whether or not to
use the sixth overall pick on a
quarterback so
i can tell you right now um that they
haven't made a decision that they're
going to take a quarterback at six
overall
in part because they don't know who's
going to be there and they haven't gone
through that process yet
but they also have not made the decision
we're going forward with jalen hurts and
we're going to take a player to another
position at sixth overall
they're very much going to look at those
three quarterbacks and it makes sense to
too dan i mean
this i mean howie roseman's been there
21 years
this is only the third time that they've
had a pick
in the top 10 that they that they were
slotted to have like the one steal they
traded up for but
in howie roseman's first year they had
the sixth overall pick in 2013 they had
the fourth overall pick those are the
only
two times previous to this one that they
had a top ten pick while howie rosen's
been there do you think russell wilson
is being shopped or wants to be shopped
i think the seahawks may be sending him
a little bit of a message you know
and i don't the seahawks were real happy
with how he handled
um that period of a few days and i think
part of it was on your show right um
i you know i i sort of view this as
like he sort of piggybacked on what
happened with aaron rodgers where aaron
rodgers to me what aaron rodgers did in
the 24 hours after the nfc title game
was
looked at the other three conference
finalists saw the bills
went and got stefan diggs for josh allen
saw how aggressive the bucks
were putting around putting people
around tom brady how aggressive the
chiefs were putting people around
patrick mahomes
and i think in a way it was aaron
rodgers taking public
some of the frustration that he may have
had in the past
on how aggressive the packers have been
and then i think you know
that kind of gave russell wilson cover
to try and do the same thing
which i think really really you know
like privately angered some people in
the seahawks organization and so
yeah i think taking calls on russell
wilson's way different than trading him
and taking calls on russell wilson could
be sending him a message like hey listen
like you know this is
this is a this is gonna be a partnership
and if you aren't gonna hold up your end
of the bargain
like we aren't afraid to go and dip our
toes in that water either
yeah i i think it was um i think
there's more to it i think it was
calculated on russ's part
yeah yeah i'd agree he knew and then you
know when i
talked to a source that said you know
that this relationship
can't last it's not sustainable like
that was to add to what
russ who uncharacteristically said this
about the seahawks and
you know once he opened the door i
realized he was opening the door to
welcome me
in to ask questions about this so like
here's one thing i would say
there's a lot of history there like
there is i mean you look at it
the two contract negotiations did get a
little sideways before they did deals
right
and then you have the history going back
to 25th 2014
2015 um you know when they were
contending for when they won the super
bowl in 2013
and how the defensive players there felt
about russell so that's part of the
history
and you've had russell kind of grumble
about
the offensive line in the past this
isn't the first time that's happened in
the past so that's part of the history
and so yeah i think there's always been
sort of
like this tension and that's the way
pete carroll built his program if you
look at the way that it was when they
were at their best there was definitely
tension in that building
i think there's always been sort of this
lingering underlying tension
between wilson and the seahawks and
like does that resolve itself with him
being traded out of town i don't think
so right now
um i don't think it'll happen this year
like does it eventually mean he's
wearing another uniform before he's done
playing football
that i could definitely see yeah he's
albert breer senior nfl reporter joining
us
uh the situation with dak prescott i
don't know if jerry jones stumbled
into something because this wasn't
orchestrated but
he might just franchise back and say let
me see if you come back from the ankle
injury
and if if we don't make the playoffs i
got an easy out here
and i not that this is what he designed
two years ago or less than two years ago
but
does jerry want to sign him up long term
or does he want to see him
you know perform another year i think
the injury is a factor
um you know i don't know he's out of the
woods with that either i mean this isn't
an acl you know and
they've got nacl to the point where guys
routinely come back from it
um i do think that the injury is a
factor here
um i would say this like i i just
i i think at this point dak is way past
the point where
any player would in his right mind
give the team any sort of hometown
discount because of everything that he's
been through
and because they didn't do a deal after
three years the way a lot of franchise
quarterbacks get deals done after three
years because
last year the negotiation you know was
so just kind of back and forth and back
and forth over the course of the off
season
i mean now i mean dak has incurred
32 games of injury risk since they were
eligible to do a deal and
generally when players incur that amount
of injury risk
and keep playing on what they feel like
are below market deals well
at that point the players will be less
willing to do
a any sort of team friendly deal so
you know now you have to if if you
accept that you got to look at dex
leverage right now they tag them that's
37 million dollars lump sum for this
year
if they tag them again next year dan
that franchise tag number
is over 52 million dollars so
dak by sitting on his hands right now
right
he can collect 37 million dollars for
this year
and then next year he either gets free
agency at 28 years old
or he gets a 52 million dollar check
like that's what the cowboys have to
beat now like so if you want to talk
about leverage
the cowboys have to put something in
front of dak prescott
that is better than 37 million now and
either
52 million or free agency next year and
it's going to be tough for them to beat
that they could have got a bargain if
yeah if they
like two years ago they could have
gotten a bargain so
here's the here's the counter to that
argument though like you get like to get
a bargain you go in early and do it
after three years right
look at jared goff and carson wentz are
you sold on dak prescott
that he is not carson wentz and jared
goff yeah i mean i think he had a really
good situation his first year and i
think that he was
propped up to some degree his first year
which happens with a lot of young
quarterbacks so
i think having the number one rushing
you know what the number one running
game in the league
zeke elliott uh won the rushing title um
you know as a rookie all those different
you know circumstances that played into
you know that 2016 season i think you
could say to some degree dak was propped
up
i think what we saw at the beginning of
this year before he got hurt
was significant in that things weren't
perfect
around him right before he got hurt like
we saw the offensive line issues we saw
the running game struggle we saw
the defense really have problems and
really to me
what signing a quarterback to the big
second contract is about is
okay now you're not going to have the
freedom to put the same level of pieces
around him because he's going to eat up
a bunch of your cap space
can he make up the difference and i
think what we saw early in the 2020
season
is that dak is capable of making up the
difference because
we saw it happen in a lot of different
ways early in the year
now you know the the obvious thing
that's complicating this is the injury
and whether he comes back and he's the
same guy
but i do think like if if you're
convinced that he's going to be the same
guy
that he was at the beginning of 2020 he
showed us
something that maybe we never saw from
jared goff in la and we never saw from
carson weins in philadelphia
always great thank you albert for making
yourself available we appreciate it
you got dan that's albert breer senior
nfl reporter lead content strategist for
the monday morning quarterback